mpox formerly known as monkey pox is a
rare disease caused by a very tiny germ
called the empox virus
like most viral infections empox may
start with flu-like symptoms including
feeling exhausted chills
fever
headache
muscle aches swollen lymph nodes and a
stuffy nose sore throat or cough
these symptoms are usually followed by a
flat rash on certain areas of your body
such as the genitals anal region face
mouth hands feet and chest
then the rash can turn into raised
pimple-like sores that are filled with
fluid or pus
and the rash is often very painful
this rash generally lasts for about a
week before beginning to crust scabbing
over and finally falling off as new skin
appears
while there is no specific treatment for
M pox most people have mild symptoms and
get better without needing one the
illness lasts about two to four weeks
however since the rash is often very
painful your healthcare provider May
advise you to take pain relievers to
help you feel better
if your immune system is weak or if you
are pregnant and at risk for becoming
very ill you may be prescribed a
medication called an antiviral
to prevent catching ampocs here are some
things you can do avoid close contact
with people who have empox until after
their rash has completely healed
avoid close contact with animals such as
monkeys and rodents that may be infected
avoid touching areas and items that a
person with mpox has used
and wash your hands often with soap or
an alcohol-based hand sanitizer
people at high risk for getting M pox
may be advised to get a vaccine that is
effective against both smallpox and M
pox
people at high risk are those who have
had close skin to skin contact in the
last two weeks with someone who has or
may have M pox especially with men who
have sex with men in a geographic area
where Mbox is spreading and anyone whose
job May expose them to orthopox viruses
such as lab workers and healthcare
workers
the vaccines contain a weakened orthopox
virus called vaccinia which cannot
multiply or cause disease
since orthopox viruses are so similar
the vaccines can help protect against
both the variola virus that causes
smallpox and the Mbox virus
if you were born before 1972 and had the
smallpox vaccine at that time or before
you may have some protection from severe
disease but you are not protected
against getting infected or infecting
someone else
for more information about the treatment
and prevention of Mbox talk to your
Healthcare practitioner